jetzt geht es mal wieder ans eingemachte
mit alexei vecsey wenn erklärt wird
warum leidenschaft leidenschaft und
warum pixum anders ist als andere
talkshows das zeigt sich jetzt mal
wieder
also seid gespannt auf einige einblicke
von alexei vecsey die lage ist schön
ja ja bei dir bei mir so super ich fühle
mich sehr wohl in hamburg du ja wenn du
dich teilweise so ultra stressig wäre
wäre es traurig perfekt hier in hamburg
und ist es ultra stressig weil weil man
kriegt vielleicht zwischendurch mit über
facebook twitter oder weiß der geier
es gibt immer was zu tun aber schöne
dinge zu tun
schöne dinge da ist nicht nur youtube
was machst du sonst noch es ist
hauptsächlich boni und nebenbei halb die
normalen projekte man sagt ja wenn man
arbeitet ja auch normal die neben
youtube es gibt ja nicht nur youtube in
dem das gehört mit dazu klar was machst
du da naja so überhaupt zum schreiben
was man kann es umschreiben ja es hat
viel mit mit sprecher geschichten zu tun
ja weil viele auf youtube wissen ja auch
dass ich mal für den einen oder anderen
auch gerne mal meine stimme leihen
was ja auch was ich immer cool finde
weil die leute haben so viele
vorstellungen von gewissen dingen das
macht spaß es umzusetzen
das ist ein großteil und gerade in
sachen uni geht es ja gerade in dem in
einem studienfach filmregie um das thema
seelisches arbeiten und das natürlich
immer spannend gerade wenn man eigene
größere filmprojekte plant die leider
nicht auf youtube zu sehen sind
wie man das ganze schafft oder stemmen
kann gerade wenn man noch frisch in dem
bereich ist aber es ist aber die
herausforderung aber es ist schön und
soviel kann ich glaube ich erst mal dazu
sagen wer fühlt sich manchmal zerrissen
sind ja aber wer tut das nicht oder ich
könnte mir jobs vorstellen
also wenn ich als gärtner arbeiten würde
da braucht man ruhe und gelassenheit da
würde ich vielleicht nicht so gibt es
stimmen aber ich glaube für die dinge
für die man auch wirklich für die das
herz schlägt ist man zerrissen was uns
würde es nicht funktionieren
wie hat sich das ganze entwickelt war
das von vornherein klar ich muss in
diese richtung oder gab es irgend so ein
zufall irgend moment nein es hat sich so
entwickelt glaube ich damals es ist es
ist zwar eine geschichte die viele
wahrscheinlich schon gehört haben
vielleicht du sogar schon gehört hast
aber es war wirklich so dass damals mein
vater der war so ein bisschen mit foto
und video tätig also privat nur und von
ihnen habe ich teilweise dann die die
kameras bekommen natürlich mit vorsicht
und machtlos nicht kaputt was soll das
aber nach und nach entwickelte sich
dafür eine leidenschaft für bewegte
bilder erst mal für standbilder und dann
für bewegte bilder und ja das ist das so
weit entwickelt hat dass ich ohne dem
gar nicht mehr kannten sei es jetzt
youtube oder andere bewegtbild
geschichten fühlte sich denn vor oder
hinter der kamera oder es kommt drauf an
also ich fühle mich vor der kamera
genauso gut wie hinter der kamera nur
man arbeitet einfach anders es kommt
immer darauf an welche arbeit liebsten
also wäre es anders gefragt was wäre ein
traum
hinter der kamera regie zu führen und
die schauspieler zu steuern oder lieber
vor der kamera sich sagen lassen was man
tun wollt dann wird es ja dann
irgendwann mal sein
ja das schöne ist er hinter der kamera
ist ja nicht nur schauspieler steuern
sondern auch ganz viel aber ich glaube
es ist noch zu früh um zu sagen was
wirklich jetzt meinen traum im endeffekt
sein könnte ich finde beides momentan
noch total spannend und macht beides und
macht beides auch sehr gerne
von daher wenn wir uns in ein oder zwei
jahren nochmal treffen zum hintergrund
kann ich glaube ich zu 90 prozentiger
wahrscheinlichkeit sagen was im
endeffekt mein traum
diesbezüglich wird und geht das heißt du
brauchst nur ein zwei jahre um das muss
ja vielleicht vielleicht sogar mehr
vielleicht sogar mehr was muss da
passieren erfahrung mehr raum sammeln um
das sagen zu können was für erfahrungen
muss man sammeln um das machen zu wenden
projekte machen kontakte knüpfen
das ganze kennenlernen und dann zu
wissen womit man auch selber klar kommt
das ist eben das was ich noch brauche
oder mehr haben möchte
wir haben gerade gesprochen über dieses
vor der hinter der kamera zu stehen vor
der kamera zu stehen bedeutet ja auch
ein wenig ruhm und rasieren und treffs
mehr oder weniger damit klarkommen was
gerade gesagt ist das ein punkt mit dem
du klar kommst alle oder wo war der
punkt wo du erstens merkt es was sich da
tut und wie war das dann müsste ja klar
kommen gutes stichwort genau also am
anfang war es tatsächlich so man hat die
zahlen auf dem bildschirm gesehen 50.000
abonnenten jetzt zum thema youtube und
man hat erst mal gar nichts davon
gemerkt aber sobald man dann zum
beispiel richtung gamescom geht oder so
was also plätze wo viele jüngere leute
sind dann fällt einem aufbau man wird ja
doch gesehen
was sehr schön ist was wirklich schön
ist aber am anfang
ich bin ich sagen merkwürdig es war
merkwürdig aber es war was war neu der
neue wirklich neu war normalerweise hat
man das ja nicht dass man viel straße
geht und man kauft sich ein eisen auf
einmal stehen hinter einem 5 in nette
mädels du bist doch der von youtube ja
aber auf youtube gibt es doch viele wer
bin ich denn er du bist doch der alex
und dann mit denen auch so spontan ins
gespräch zu kommen obwohl man sie noch
nie gesehen hat oder ist es trotzdem so
die canon einen so als ob man weiß nicht
sich täglich fünf jahre lang sehen würde
aber man selbst noch gar nicht gesehen
das ist erstmal ganz verrückt aber schön
das ist schön und dann jetzt nach und
nach kennt man das ja wie das ist
aber das heißt nicht dass es weniger
schön ist sondern es ist ehrlich gesagt
es wird von mal zu mal aufregender weil
je mehr leute einsehen und kennt über
youtube desto unterschiedlicher wird ja
auch der kreis der personen die einen
sehen und wenn dazwischen die hater sind
die man heute schon mal begegnet die er
ja die hat man immer mal wieder in
berlin war es grüße an die berliner
da hieß es ja bohr so ein typ der so
aussieht und so sinkt der sollte am
besten im keller bleiben also auf
offener straße ist singst du ja gar
nicht so schlecht
dankeschön ich versuche jetzt persönlich
immer mehr dahinter zu kommen was das
für menschen sind jetzt wirklich gucken
am anfang waren es vielleicht wirklich
nur erstmal mädels die um finden es toll
aber jetzt wo sich auch das programm
noch mit ändert sind auch leute die
nicht nur interesse am singen haben oder
an dem alex auf youtube sondern
tatsächlich auch einem alex den es
hinter youtube gibt fernab vom sinkt zum
beispiel und das finde ich spannend wer
ist der alex hinter youtube
ich habe ein buch dazu geschrieben ja ja
ok bücher schreiben
so ein komischer krachten er hat auch
schon denken ja weiter ist weniger mich
richtig richtig gerster alex hinter der
kamera hinter youtube anders also viele
verwechseln das glaube ich alex bei
youtube und alex in echtz die die wissen
teilweise nicht dass der artist auf
youtube auch eine gewisse figur ist ja
schon erklärt er oder so natürlich
versucht man immer so viel wie geht von
sich selbst einzubauen
aber ich laufe jetzt nicht also liegt
nicht grundsätzlich aber auch nicht
laufen nicht grundsätzlich durch die
straßen und wege mit bildungs durch die
gegend oder oder oder spiele
kartoffelpüree ins gesicht so schlimm
ist es privat nicht aber ich bin schon
schon auf gewisse art und weise ein teil
von dem was man auf youtube sieht klar
was es würde das glaube ich auch nicht
funktionieren
wie kannst du das trennen das frage ich
mich auch immer für den einsatz gibt der
wirklich schwere fälle ja dadurch es
gibt leute die kommen damit super
zurecht
es ist ja es ist schwierig also ich habe
ehrlich gesagt nicht so große gedanken
über gemacht wie ich sowas wirklich
bewusst trenne oder nicht trennen man
versucht es oder ich versuche es
persönlich so zu machen
ich mache meine youtube geschichten und
sobald ein youtube video oder eine
youtube produktion erst mal fertig ist
heißt es für mich erst mal einen halben
tag oder wenigstens einen tag etwas
komplett anderes zu machen
gärtner und zum beispiel gerne arbeit
und nebenbei wenn es bei einer
vernünftigen familie ist vielleicht auch
noch mal
die nette tochter oder milch von nebenan
mit run zu nehmen ein quatsch das ganze
wirklich so zu treffen dass man sagt
zwischen youtube und dem was privat
passiert etwas zu machen das komplett
anders ist das heißt handy weg
technische geräte weg und zum beispiel
einen halben tag lang nur an die elbe
setzen
ich glaube jetzt bei uns passt nicht
weil hier
diese flugzeuge über uns hinweg fliegt
sauber hören uns aber wir sind ja
richtig schwer
das ist das ist die sache
ich habe mir noch nicht so viele
gedanken über das ist einfach strikt
pausen dazwischen machen und den kopf
wieder frei zu bekommen und das nicht zu
sehr mit dem privaten leben zu
vermischen
weil es besteht ja immer die gefahr dass
meine vielleicht tatsächlich so rumläuft
auch im privatleben und das ist jetzt
ein doofes beispiel aber es ist das
extrembeispiel dass du mit leuten auf
einmal mit den gegenständen gesicht
rumpf hummels oder anschließt oder
sarkastische ganz anders ich frage mich
aber manchmal ob nicht jeder eigentlich
diese zweite persönlichkeit in sich
trägt
die ja eigentlich nicht ausleben kann
aber die kamera ist in weiß wirklich ein
ventil
vielleicht kommt wohl oft den menschen
immer drauf an
es ist für dich mit viel also ist das
wohl sagen das ist teurer sich das habe
ein hoch philosophisches thema kommen
passiert abo zumal hier ist ein ventil
ist es jetzt zum beispiel ein ventil wo
ich vor der kamera sitze vielleicht
manchmal vielleicht manchmal obwohl wie
gesagt so genau habe ich mir das
wirklich noch nie überlegt ich glaube
ich würde jetzt mit dir beispielsweise
auch nicht anders reden wenn die kamera
aus wäre deswegen ist es eine schöne
frage die ich nehme ich mit nach hause
nehmen werde
und darüber noch einmal mehr gedanken
machen werde ist es für mich ein ventil
oder nicht vielleicht gibt es dann einen
passenden erklären wo ich ganz sagen das
wird in der klärwärter dargestellt eine
sehr schöne frage hätte ich manchmal das
ventil ganz auch er wie der da hinten
gerade hallo oder ein bisschen wieder zu
oder oder kamera posieren dieses hast du
das eigentlich hilft dir da die die
ausbildung auf das ist ja ein studium an
der medienakademie hier in hamburg der
und im fach regie lernt man auch viel
über schauspielführung
er hilft ihr das dabei hätte ich gewisse
dinge schon vorher gewusst werden glaube
ich viele videos auf youtube ganz anders
gelaufen sind die detail nicht nein
sondern ich stehe dahinter also hinter
jedem video
es ist eine entwicklung wie du sagtest
sich das entwickelt und wenn ich mir zum
beispiel videos anschauen von vor ein
oder zwei jahren macht man natürlich
irgendwie drüber aber auf der anderen
seite der eu für damals das hat man
schon hinbekommen
wieso nicht und wenn dabei sachen bei
sind die man heute wahrscheinlich nicht
machen will würde weil man älter wird
okay dann ist es in ordnung
das ist absolut in ordnung ist und ich
weiß nicht wie es bei dir sagst du
jünger was hast wahrscheinlich auch
anders witze gerissen als heute oder ich
finde viele sehen das immer so salopp so
alles super alles schule alle sony aber
weil vieles was da entsteht das gehört
ja zu einem was womit man ja angefangen
hat und deswegen auch wenn ich kenne das
ja von vielen kollegen schule dorf und
unido und alles kacke und ich habe keine
lust aber was da entsteht darf man nicht
auf die leichte schulter nehmen also
nicht einfach mit mir egal
es ist ein teil was dazu gehört was man
später macht leidenschaft ist das was
wichtig ist dabei für dich ja ohne der
würde man glaube ich nach ein oder zwei
stunden das notebook zu klappen oder
sein heft zuklappen und nach hause gehen
weil man fällt immer auf die schnauze
man hat immer fruchtbar so was man hat
immer ausgaben wo man sich denkt dafür
würde ich mir jetzt lieber vielleicht
das t shirt kaufen aber das geld landet
dann zum beispiel wo anders man hat
immer streitereien so viel gehört dazu
und wenn diese leidenschaft fehlt
funktioniert sich das heißt leidenschaft
ist wirklich etwas was leiden schafft
das ist schön leidenschaft des wassers
leidet aber trotzdem am ende eine
unglaubliche genugtuung wenn man das
immer so als bild wenn du dann stell dir
vor du hast gerade andré fertig bekommen
so wie damals bei uns der crysis dreh
mit den socken auf youtube das war
wirklich anstrengend wir waren danach
durchgeschwitzt mit blut beschmiert also
kunstblut jetzt geklappt war waren total
dreckig und im nachhinein funktionierte
auch teilweise was an der technik nicht
aber ganz normal und wir saßen da nur
noch um einen gott 14 uhr noch einen
kaffee und ab ins bett aber wenn man
denn das video am ende sieht dann geht
eine immer so wie sie das herz auf was
ist es ist schön und wenn dann noch
zusätzlich ein paar zuschauer oder fans
ein paar nette zeilen dazu schreiben
dann würde man am liebsten
dahinschmelzen regenbogen spucken ich
meine deshalb besser geht es dann gar
nicht okay also ein traumberuf und
youtube ein traum und alles ein traum
aber auch ein preis ist genau was da ist
es nur ein traum wenn man die albträume
überlebt ja ok darf man nicht vergessen
dann wünsche ich dass noch viele
albträume über liebst dankeschön und
noch mehr talk gibt es bei pixum zum
beispiel den mit matze knop der darüber
spricht der mann hat nämlich eine
klassische gesangsausbildung wer hätte
das gedacht und auch bei al ahli muss
man sagen wer hätte das gedacht wenn er
sagt wir hatten keine heizung also was
interessiert euch mehr klick drauf und
ansonsten die war das noch genau
bis dann bleibt dran